wir haben glaube ich nicht die meinung
von herrn laschet und das ist das was
viele unsere zuschauer ja nicht wissen
da sitzen ja in einem nebenzimmer wo
auch immer berater und da sagt einer um
gottes willen erwähne maße nicht hier
kriegt dann rote ohren weil die frage
maßen kommt was macht er jetzt was macht
er jetzt ja er beantwortet die frage
nicht ich möchte dass die menschen die
sich zum kanzler unserer bundesrepublik
wählen lassen selber entscheiden ich
habe eine meinung zu maßen und hier ist
sie dass der in meiner partei ist ist
ärgerlich ich konnte es nicht verhindern
oder er sagt unsere partei hat platz für
viele auch für den da ist zum beispiel
bei uns dieses ausgrenzen sehr viel
schneller da sind die amerikaner die für
die ich nicht hier sitze einfach eher
bereit dinge auszuhalten idioten zu
integrieren und sagen der erzählt einen
mist er ist aber mehr oder weniger teil
unserer veranstaltung die einen finden
dass es keinen mist ist ich halte das
ist aber dass man legt sich zumindest
dann habe ich einen satz jäger ich sehe
das ein wenig anders ich hätte an der
stelle wenn ich ins armin laschet heute
abend gewesen wäre hätte ich gesagt
lassen sie uns wenige persönlichkeiten
sprechen weil ich gebe dir recht es muss
den zuschauer interessieren fest aber
jetzt mal ganz ehrlich sind die
personalie boris palmer dann die
personalie maßen der zuschauer da
draußen möchte wissen was passiert mit
meiner rente was passiert wenn der
zuschauer da draußen würde ich sagen
möchte doch auch wissen ja ich jemanden
der sich klar äußern und nicht in einem
cdu-wahlkampf bin und ich habe dort auch
noch in einem problematischen teil
unseres landes in dem es darum geht die
mauer nach rechts zuzumachen ich hab da
ein der möglicherweise auch solche leute
bin kann die sonst die fdp könnten dann
möchte ich doch hören kann kann der mann
der kanzler werden will etwas klares
dazu sagen und nicht sein und nein ich
sage am vorletzten für wege mich jetzt
bewege ich mich mal auf dieses dünne eis
man könnte ja durchaus die meinung
vertreten das ist sogar eine große tat
von dermaßen dass er die brandmauer nach
rechts zu macht durch seine politischen
positionen
laschet hat aber schon aufgenommen aus
angst nein nein der ist teil des rechten
täglichen
anders man kann aber auch ganz anders
sehen man kann sagen ich bin froh dass
wir auch solche stimmen in der partei
haben die menschen eine politische
heimat geben bevor sie abdriften zu
nazis und das alles muss man halt
einfach einmal sagen ohne diese dauernde
verfluchte angst denn daran und dann
hinterher an die allgemeinen seinen
maßen ist dem anderen eben sein palme
aber das werde ich das noch das bewegt
mich wirklich das fand ich von berbalk
also absolut auch
niederträchtig palma und maßen zu
verkoppeln also der vorwurf gegen maßen
lautet ja er sei so weit rechts dass man
es schon unangenehm findet der vorwurf
gegen palma ist er hat in einem
ironischen instagram oder twitter oder
facebook facebook kommentar eine
rassistische formulierung verwendet
hinterher ist dann diskutiert worden ob
es überhaupt realistisch waren das eine
ist pippifax palma und das anderes
ernstzunehmende partei positionierung
strategie das miteinander zu verquicken
ist extrem perfekt war
[Musik]